السكان نائمون هناك
صاروخ روسي اخترق شققهم
الإنقاذ في هذه المدينة الصغيرة الأوكرانية الواقعة في وسط مدينة أومان
في مكان الحادث بسرعة ،
لذا كان من أوائل الذين
كانت هناك صرخات مروعة للأطفال ،
كان الانفجار قويًا للغاية وبدأت
المنازل تهتز في
المناطق المجاورة  أول امرأة انسحبناها كانت
امرأة على قيد الحياة تم وضعها في
سيارة الإسعاف لكنها توفيت في المستشفى ، حيث كان عدد
القتلى يتسلق خلال اليوم الذي
أخبرتنا فيه هذه السيدة أنها سمعت أن
الصاروخ وضع أطفالها في حوض الاستحمام
والوسائد فوق رؤوسهم وأملوا
ذلك.  قالت إن
الكثير من الأطفال يعيشون هنا في جرح من
الخرسانة والأنقاض حيث حطمت
حياة الأبرياء
العائلات والأصدقاء في
انتظار يائس أخبار أحبائهم
وأخبرتنا هذه السيدة بأن صديقتها في
الطابق الثامن نجت ولكن
ابنتا الصديقين واحدة 13  عامًا والآخرون
السبعة الآخرون لا يزالون في عداد
المفقودين ، يأخذنا رجل الإطفاء إلى الأعلى لرؤية تلك
الطوابق العلوية
على السطح تسعة طوابق فوق
فرق الإنعاش ،
انظر كيف انهار المبنى حرفيًا
هنا ، يجب أن
يبنوا هنا مباشرة وفطيرة الطوابق
لأسفل  مع انقلاب بعض السقف
هناك
من هنا ، فإن الضرر أكثر
تدميراً من
أكثر من نصف شقق المبنى البالغ عددها 46 والتي
تم تدميرها ، لذا سيأتي رجال الإطفاء
هنا وكما
فعلوا طوال اليوم في هذه المهمة الخطيرة
هنا يعرضون أنفسهم حرفيًا
للخطر  في محاولة للتعافي لإخلاء
الموقع لإحضار
المسؤولين الأوكرانيين الراسخين يعتقدون أن كل هذا
الدمار الناجم عن
صاروخ كروز خفي روسي واحد من طراز kh-101 هو
الهجوم الأكثر دموية على المدنيين
منذ يناير / كانون الثاني ، حيث
سجل 109 أشخاص يعيشون هنا مع
سقوط العديد منهم.  لا يزال
مجهول المصير وهذا الجهد هنا للعثور على
فقدان المفقودين هائل من
الشرطة ، رجال الإطفاء الذين يقولون
إنهم سيعملون طوال الليل
لن يستسلموا ، لقد رأينا
الشرطة هنا تقوم باختبار الحمض النووي
لشرطة العائلات  يقوم علماء النفس بتقديم المشورة
لأفراد الأسرة الحزينة هنا ، إنه
تدفق هائل للدعم ، إنها
رسالة للأوكرانيين لأنفسهم ، إنها
رسالة إلى الرئيس بوتين من
الأوكرانيين ، لن تجعلهم أي قدر من القصف يدفعهم
للتخلي عن نيك روبرسون سي إن إن أومان
أوكرانيا